"Juez, quiero decirle algo. Quiero decirle algo.
La he estado mirando
y Ud. no es una hipócrita.
Ud. trata a todos por igual".
Eso me lo dijo una prostituta transgénero
quien antes de llegar al banquillo
había despedido a su abogado de oficio,
insultado al oficial de la corte
y gritado a la persona sentada a su lado.
"No sé qué estás mirando. Soy más linda que la chica con la que estás".
(Risas)
Ella me dijo esto
después de decir su nombre masculino lo suficientemente bajo
para que pudiera ser registrado,
pero dije su nombre femenino lo suficientemente fuerte
para que pudiera caminar por el pasillo hacia la mesa del consejero con dignidad.
Esto es justicia procesal, también conocida como equidad procesal,
en su mejor momento.
Soy hija de un recolector de basura afroestadounidense
quien nació en Harlem
y pasó sus veranos en el Sur segregado.
Soy la hija de una peluquera dominicana.
Lo hago para asegurarme de que siguen prestando atención.
(Risas)
Soy la hija de una peluquera dominicana
que vino a este país para tener una mejor vida para sus hijos todavía por nacer.
Mis padres me enseñaron a tratar a todas las personas con dignidad y respeto,
sin importar su aspecto; sin importar su ropa,
sin importar cómo hablaran.
Ya ven, los principios de la equidad
me los enseñaron a una corta edad,
e inconscientemente fue la lección más importante
que llevé conmigo al banco de la corte municipal de Newark.
Y porque sacada del patio de recreo
a la corta edad de 10 años para traducir para miembros de la familia
cuando comenzaron a migrar a EE.UU.,
entiendo lo desalentador que puede ser para una persona novata,
navegar por cualquier sistema de gobierno.
Todos los días en todo EE.UU. y en todo el mundo,
las personas se encuentran con nuestros tribunales,
y es un lugar extraño, intimidante
y a menudo hostil hacia ellos.
Están confundidos sobre la naturaleza de sus cargos,
molestos por sus encuentros con la policía,
enfrentándose a consecuencias que podrían afectar sus relaciones,
sus finanzas e incluso su libertad.
Déjenme trazarles una foto
de lo que es para la persona promedio ante nuestros tribunales.
Primero, están molestos por tener que pasar el control la seguridad de la corte.
Tras el control de seguridad de la corte, caminan por el edificio,
haciendo la misma pregunta a diferentes personas
obteniendo diferentes respuestas.
Cuando finalmente llegan a donde se supone que deben estar,
se ponen muy mal al verse ante los tribunales.
¿Qué pensarían si dijera
que pueden mejorar la experiencia de la corte popular,
aumentar el cumplimiento de la ley
y las órdenes judiciales,
mientras se aumenta la confianza del público
en el sistema de justicia
mediante una idea sencilla?
Bueno, esa idea sencilla es la justicia procesal
y es un concepto que dice
que si las personas perciben que son tratadas de manera justa
y con dignidad y respeto,
ellos obedecerán la ley.
Eso es lo que el profesor de Yale Tom Tyler encontró
cuando comenzó a estudiar en los años 70
por qué la gente obedece la ley.
Descubrió que si las personas ven el sistema de justicia
como una autoridad legítima para imponer reglas y regulaciones,
ellos las seguirían.
Su investigación concluyó
que la gente estaría satisfecha
con los fallos del juez,
incluso cuando el juez fallara en contra de ellos,
si perciben que fueron tratados con justicia
y con dignidad y respeto.
Y ¿cómo empieza esa percepción de justicia?
Comienza con la forma en que los jueces hablan a los participantes de la corte.
Ser juez
a veces es como tener un asiento de reserva para un reality show trágico
sin interrupciones para comerciales
y sin final de temporada.
Es verdad.
La gente llega a mí esposada,
drogada, deprimida, hambrienta
y mentalmente enferma.
Cuando veía que su necesidad de ayuda
era mayor que mi miedo a parecer vulnerable en el banco,
me di cuenta de que no solo necesitaba hacer algo,
sino que, de hecho, podría hacer algo.
La buena noticia es que los principios de la justicia procesal son fáciles
y puede implementarse tan rápido como mañana.
Lo mejor es que se puede hacer sin coste alguno.
(Risas)
El primer principio es la voz.
Hay que a las personas la oportunidad de hablar,
incluso cuando no les dejas hablar.
Hay que explicarlo.
"Señor, no le dejo hablar ahora.
Ud. no tiene abogado,
no quiero que diga nada que perjudique su caso".
Para mí, asignar trabajos de redacción a los acusados
ha sido una forma tremenda de darles voz.
Recientemente le asigné una redacción a un estudiante universitario de 18 años.
Lamentó su cargo de consumo de alcohol siendo menor de edad.
Mientras estaba de pie ante mí leyendo su ensayo,
su voz se quebraba y sus manos temblaban,
dijo que le preocupaba haberse convertido en un alcohólico como su madre,
que había muerto un par de meses antes
por una enfermedad hepática generada por el alcohol.
Ya ven, asignando una carta a mi padre, una carta a mi hijo,
"Si supiera entonces lo que sé ahora..".
"Si creyera en algo positivo de mí mismo,
¿Cómo sería de diferente mi vida?"
le da a la persona la oportunidad de ser introspectiva,
de verse por dentro,
que es, de todos modos, donde están todas las respuestas.
Pero también se les da una oportunidad
para compartir algo con el tribunal que va más allá
de sus antecedentes penales y de sus cargos.
El siguiente principio es la neutralidad.
Al aumentar la confianza pública en el sistema de justicia,
la neutralidad es primordial.
No se puede percibir que el juez está favoreciendo un lado sobre el otro.
El juez tiene que tomar una decisión consciente de no decir cosas como:
"mi oficial", "mi fiscal", "mi abogado defensor".
Y esto es un desafío cuando trabajamos en entornos
donde tienes personas asignadas a tus tribunales,
las mismas personas que entran y salen de sus tribunales también.
Cuando pienso en la neutralidad,
me acuerdo de cuando era una recién graduada de derecho de Rutgers
y una abogada recién horneada,
y entré en un arbitraje y me saludaron dos hombres de pelo gris
que estaban bromeando sobre el último juego de golf que jugaron juntos
y planeaban salidas sociales futuras.
Sabía que mi cliente no podría obtener una oportunidad justa en ese foro.
El siguiente principio es entender.
Es crítico que los participantes de la corte entiendan el proceso,
las consecuencias del proceso
y lo que se espera de ellos.
Me gusta decir que la jerga legal es el lenguaje usado para confundir.
(Risas)
Soy muy consciente de que las personas que aparecen ante mí,
muchas tienen escasa formación
y el inglés es a menudo su segundo idioma.
Así que hablo inglés sencillo en el tribunal.
Un gran ejemplo de esto fue cuando era una juez joven:
me refiero una juez más joven.
(Risas)
Cuando era una juez más joven, un juez superior vino a mí,
me dio un guion y dijo:
"Si cree que alguien tiene problemas de salud mental,
hágales estas preguntas y obtendrá su evaluación".
Y la primera vez que vi a alguien
que yo pensaba, que tenía un problema de salud mental,
fui a por mi guion y comencé a hacer preguntas.
"Señor, toma psico, psicotró...
medicación psicotrópica?"
"No".
"Señor, ¿ha tratado con un psiquiatra antes?"
Pero era obvio que la persona padecía una enfermedad mental.
Un día, en mi frustración, decidí eliminar el guion y hacer una pregunta.
"Señora, ¿toma medicamentos para despejar su mente?"
"Sí, juez, tomo a Haldol por mi esquizofrenia,
Xanax por mi ansiedad".
La pregunta funciona incluso cuando no.
"Sr. L, ¿toma medicamentos para aclarar su mente?"
"No, juez, no tomo medicamentos para aclarar mi mente.
Tomo medicamentos para detener las voces en mi cabeza,
pero mi mente está bien".
(Risas)
Ya ven, una vez que las personas entienden la pregunta,
ellos pueden darte información valiosa
eso permite a la corte tomar decisiones significativas
sobre los casos que están ante ellos.
El último principio es respeto,
que sin él ninguno de los otros principios puede funcionar.
El respeto puede ser tan simple como:
"Buenas tardes señor". "Buenos días señora".
Mirar a la persona frente a ti a los ojos
especialmente cuando los estás condenando.
Es cuando digo: "¿Cómo está hoy?
¿Y qué le pasa?
Y no como un saludo,
sino como alguien que está realmente interesado en la respuesta.
El respeto es la diferencia entre decir:
"Señora, ¿tiene dificultades
de entender la información en la documentación?"
o "Puede leer y escribir, ¿verdad?"
si una se da cuenta de que hay un problema de alfabetización.
Y lo bueno del respeto es que es contagioso.
La gente me ve siendo respetuosa con otras personas
y ellos aplican ese respeto a sí mismos.
Eso es lo que la prostituta transgénero me estaba diciendo.
Te estoy juzgando tanto como crees que puedes juzgarme.
No te estoy diciendo lo que pienso,
te estoy diciendo lo que he vivido,
usando la justicia procesal para cambiar la cultura en mi tribunal
y en la sala del tribunal.
Después de estar sentada cómodamente durante siete meses
como juez de un tribunal de tránsito,
me informaron que me trasladaban a la corte criminal,
a la sección segunda, a la corte criminal.
Quiero que entiendan,
que esto no era una buena noticia.
(Risas)
No lo era.
La sección segunda era conocida como la peor corte de la ciudad,
algunas personas incluso dirían que del estado.
Era el típico tribunal urbano con justicia de puerta giratoria,
es decir, el grupo de delincuentes de bajo nivel,
es decir, la fruta más baja,
la prostituta adicta a las drogas,
la persona sintecho mentalmente enferma con poca calidad de vida,
el pequeño traficante de drogas de la escuela secundaria
y jóvenes descarriados,
esas personas con cadena perpetua
30 días cada vez.
Afortunadamente, la ciudad de Newark decidió que Newarkers merecía algo mejor,
y se asociaron con el Center for Court Innovation
y el poder judicial de Nueva Jersey
para crear la Newark Community Solutions,
un programa de corte comunitario
que aplica sentencias alternativas.
Esto significa que un juez
puede sentenciar a un acusado al castigo con ayuda.
Así, un acusado que de otra manera recibiría una sentencia de cárcel
ahora puede obtener sesiones de asesoría individual,
sesiones de asesoramiento grupal, así como donación comunitaria,
que es lo que llamamos servicio comunitario.
El único problema es que este maravilloso programa
venía a Newark y ¿dónde iba a ser alojado?
En la sección segunda de la corte criminal.
Y las actitudes allí eran terribles.
Y la razón por la cual las actitudes eran terribles allí
era porque todos a los que enviaban allí
se entendía que eran enviados para ser castigados.
Los oficiales que enfrentaban acciones disciplinarias,
el defensor público y el fiscal
sentían que dictaban sentencias de cárcel de 30 días en rotación,
los jueces sentían que estaban siendo aturdidos
como una fraternidad o hermandad universitaria.
Una vez me dijeron que un abogado que trabajaba allí